[Music]
foreign welcome to the podcast today on
the show is Allison Dubois she is a
medium she is what inspired the show
medium on TV with Patricia Arquette
that's her uh ran for Seven Seasons
she's an author she has six books she
has a podcast called the dead life
I just I love talking to these sort of
out there spiritual woo-woo esoteric
psychic channeling people it's just like
a passion of mine I didn't get selfish I
didn't ask about what came through for
me although
secretly I want to but the truth is is
that she lives really close so I'm gonna
go have drinks and maybe we'll get into
that um but today on the show we talked
about a lot of reincarnation a lot about
past lives about what the dead have to
say the ways they communicate the
negative energies psycho killers and
what kind of uh charts they have and
what kind of spirit they have we talked
about plant medicine the role of
extraterrestrials and if that's
something that comes through yeah we
covered a lot of bases when it comes to
Spirit it was a really informational but
also really fun interview Allison is a
has a great energy she's very funny and
really entertaining so I think this is
going to be like a really fun
informational and enlightening episode
and in the end I'm gonna cut to the
Chase and hopefully you take this away
at the end but it's more integrated
after listening is that life is meant to
be lived by Taking Chances and to live
in your truth and you're gonna hope
actually arrive at that conclusion more
deeply when you finish the episode so
thank you for tuning in please hit
subscribe I really appreciate that it
shows me that I'm on the right track
with my guests and the message is
getting out there and the entertainment
as well also hit the bell for
notifications and let me know what you
think in the comments how funny that we
live in the same city how funny that we
were supposed to have lunch in 2006.
it's how funny that you were just
hanging out with one of my best friends
last week so that restaurant you went to
and had drinks for my friend Shannon's
birthday is like
six minutes from me she was showing me
that you're golfing pictures oh god with
the Manolo and my friend Kyle Larson oh
my God we had a show day why do you
learn Arizona have you always been here
are you fifth generation yeah damn that
is rare yeah that's what I keep hearing
but I still know my entire Kindergarten
class it's just there's more people here
from other places so we spread out a
little I guess but we're in here is it
also a hotbed for like
um I'm like super curious about
extraterrestrials and I wonder if that's
like part of something that comes
through because this whole area feels
like kind of a hotbed for those energies
that's great okay so let me tell you
what gray hockey used to be
and this is are we are we recording I'm
not sure we are okay so you mean Gray
Hawk the golf course the whole that
whole area when I was in high school we
called it body dumping territory
we used to go out there and have kegs
and that's where people used to dump
bodies and I'm friends with Gina Nolan
who's uh she was on Baywatch and she
lives up there and
she said Allison I think the house is
haunted and I said I'm pretty sure they
all are
you really know that that's what that
was but that's why the rest of us stay
uh south of Shea
yet I'm north of Shea am I in trouble no
you're fine
do you do house clearings for people I
mean if you're a friend of mine I do a
house clearing for you but otherwise
um no I have a video on YouTube telling
people how to clear a house I need to
actually put a new one of those up
um so it's not hard to do yeah but no I
do it for a close friend but yeah I'm
kind of busy if I burn enough sage in
Palo Santo does that work when you burn
the sage you actually want to go
counterclockwise with your hand while
you're while it's smoking
um and that's gonna like tell all the
energy in the house you know I want you
out of here you're not welcome
um and then when you burn the Palo Santo
or the sweet grass is what I burn that
then you do it you go and have more of a
clockwise motion and state your
intention three times of what you want
your House's energy to be clockwise
brings it in and counts clockwise exits
it sends it out right I remember that a
little bit I could never remember the
direction I went to Egypt the beginning
of last year so while while now it feels
like but we had systems and so the
systems it was like oh you had to sort
of rotate the system while shaking it in
a certain direction at certain points in
time during ritual and during our during
the things that we were doing and I
couldn't ever remember exactly why and
what the direction was so I just shook
it both ways now that could get a little
screwy check at both
you're like get out come in
are there things that we have to be
really careful about when it comes to
energies and Spirits yes
um I'm constantly telling young people
this especially
Ouija boards you do not open up portals
for anything to come through when you
can't control what's coming through so
even with what I do I have dead
University I'm the headmistress of dead
University so I've I'm the professor of
mediumship and when I talk to them about
this a lot of people with abilities have
weak borders and boundaries and so
they're all they're often overwhelmed by
mischievous entities that are sort of
messing with weak Minds is the way I
would put it so the reason the other
side comes through to children so often
is because they have weak borders and
boundaries and they're usually pretty
gentle so the other side's really drawn
to children but also people who do have
mental health issues have weak minds and
weak borders and boundaries so that can
be a problem for those people or
somebody who
has kind of suicidal energy if they have
that tone to them sort of more of a low
frequency energy they're going to draw
in low frequency energy from the other
side so you sort of draw in what you put
out
energy wise which we all know in the
dating world you draw in what you put
out so you have to be really careful
about what you put out
yeah yeah always gotta check yourself on
that one it's not really their fault
it's your fault I've had to go through a
lot of therapy to learn that that's so
funny I was always the
um it's not me it's you person
so was I that's why Drew in his super
confident guy
I just liked messing with the guys you
know like I'm like I don't need you I I
was more of the I was more like a dude
when I was out there in the dating world
so I really didn't care about getting
married or and you know having kids or
any of that so I just myself a tractor
beam every guy wants to hear that
they're like no it's you're like a hard
one to get yeah yeah and that that
worked because I got the ungettable guy
who got the ungettable girl and that
worked out
I mean I was the opposite I'm like let's
get married tomorrow
[Laughter]
sweet though that's really sweet yeah
right it wasn't so sweet when it turned
sour you know yeah um back to energies
yes so okay
um so you have to be careful the weak
boundaries right what
um why like why what is it that like
somebody out there that doesn't know
right if they have a weak boundary how
do they know if there's someone with a
weak boundary that's a good question so
with what I do especially because
anything could come through I actually
tell the other side what I want so if
for instance somebody who died comes
through two hours before a reading and
I'm making cupcakes for my daughter's
school that happened once when she was
younger and I said to him I said not now
I said you have a two o'clock at two
o'clock I'm all yours but right now
I'm not gotta go and so they sort of
fade then and then they'll come back but
I established a border and a boundary
with the other side people who play with
Ouija boards are opening it up and have
no borders and boundaries that's why
they're playing with a Ouija board in
the first place you know seeing what
will come through they just they're
doing it more for entertainment but
mischievous entities can attach to you
and they're also very alive and well
these mischievous entities in hospitals
so I often tell nurses doctors people
police officers people who spend a lot
of time around mental health or health
facilities there are certain things you
need to do to make sure you detach so
when you leave a hospital for instance
there are people that died that didn't
know that they died
so they'll try to talk to you and sort
of get in the car with you and you start
making all these wrong turns on the road
it's because something has attached
itself to you because it's looking for
somebody to listen do you actually see
them is our is it like they're in the
passenger seat like as if they're like
hey will you take me home I and they get
in and like but they're actually just an
energy they're just sometimes sometimes
it's seeing them completely uh it takes
less energy for them to show themselves
to you in your mind it takes a lot more
of their energy to project themselves
completely so it just depends on what
they need and want but they get
frustrated that their families left and
wouldn't hear them that they were okay
that they're still here again they don't
know they've passed so they're just
trying to get somebody's attention they
don't usually mean any harm but
sometimes those people died and they
were schizophrenic or there was
something going on with them and that
goes away when the body goes away but
the energy still can be a little little
screwy until they adjust on the other
side so that's something people need to
be aware of and you for instance if
somebody's as sensitive and they come in
contact with bad energy you know
everybody's been somewhere where they
meet somebody or they are in the sphere
of somebody and feel
a molestation energy sometimes you feel
like there's just something like they
shouldn't look at children in the
grocery store and you're kind of keeping
an eye on that person or you pick up a
really dark Vibe like they're a liar or
that they cheat you know something that
you're picking up on them that's
repelling to you because it's not your
energy it's not the same as your energy
so when when that happens for you you
need to make sure you go home whether
you take a bath or a shower I call it a
baptism down the drain away from me and
I visualize what I came into contact
with how it made me feel whether it be
somebody you love that has cancer and
you want to let go of that energy and
the cancers going down the drain away
from you the pain is going down the
drain away from you and you say it three
times and you visualize it going down a
long pipe until it disappears and I do
this every time I do a reading or have
worked a murder or just coming contact
with somebody I never want to come into
contact with again so that happens a lot
it does I'm an aquarius we sort of keep
to ourselves
but your electric eclectic energy
probably attracts a lot of interesting
folk yeah
um it's the hair I think but yeah for
sure just because I'm an unusual toy
they want to come and talk to me so when
I'd be on an airplane flying to a book
signing somebody would ask me what I
what I do and I just say I'm a secretary
and then they stopped talking to you it
was perfect I'm a secretary to the dead
so it's not a lie I just came up with a
way to make it okay for me and for them
to go away yeah
are some of the energies of this planet
are they human does anything ever come
through that's not human
um I've had a a couple of interactions
with angels which don't feel human okay
actually
um it was in protection for me so I felt
very safe but they they aren't like
these sweet cherubinis they were
actually sort of their wings were more
like
Shields and they stand they were
standing shoulder to shoulder with their
back to my I was in my cabin at the time
by myself trying to finish my third book
at the time and it was scary it was
Winter nobody was in the White Mountain
summer homes it was just me and I was
all alone and so it scared me and I felt
something bad something dangerous at
just outside and so I closed my eyes and
then I saw them standing around sort of
in protection and I knew I didn't have
to worry and they just stayed right
there and it was more of a feeling of
comfort a feeling that I was safe but
that I should fear them because they
weren't weak you know there's something
about them that was very strong stronger
than any human could be and it was very
intense is the best way that I could
describe what that energy was like it's
almost as if they communicate
telepathically yeah you know what their
intention is you know
um that they don't mean you any harm but
you also know that they're no doormat
you know these These are these are
warriors so I found that very
interesting and eye-opening
How does the energy come through to you
because when you said it's like a you
just it's a knowing
um that's for me how it feels when I get
other dimensional energies or
information like it it comes into my
awareness right
um so I'm curious like how it comes
through for you
um how do you see it or hear it or feel
it or know it like what's your Claires
how many Claires do you have
so for me when I'm having communication
whether it be the dead or Angels they
are telepathic they can communicate
without they'll make you feel something
they make they'll show you Visions or
um walk you through a scene as though it
were a clip from a movie they
communicate in any way that they can
through our own senses and what we have
to offer also our own vocabulary Banks
and sense of knowledge I also can hear
them sometimes they just speak out loud
and they'll yell in my ear and I'll just
repeat what they say to my client like I
said I'm just a secretary to the dead
that's really all I am and I repeat what
they say to my client and
um and that's they communicate with
however much energy they want it or can
expel it all depends on how much energy
they have people who lived stronger
lives you know connected with more
people loved big took risks you know you
would be easy to bring through because
you have an energy that exudes it's like
Beyond you know almost where sometimes
and I think it's why people see famous
people on this pedestal because they
they emit this light or project this
energy and people are drawn to it
because a lot of people have low
frequency energy so they sort of feed
off of your energy and it's why they
enjoy watching things that you're on or
listening to your podcast
so for me you know I try and do that as
much as I possibly can with
um my clients but for the dead when
they're emitting this energy because
they are a strong soul that lived a life
where they projected and they still are
that energy they're so much easier to
communicate with than people who didn't
you know people who didn't love or never
tried were angry they were born
it just depends and I've seen all kinds
but I would say I'm very lucky doing
what I do because people don't usually
want to hear from those who die who
lived a terrible life
I've actually had people ask me things
such as
my mother was awful is my mother still
awful I'm like do you want me to bring
her through or do you want to tell her
she's awful like where's your head at
you know so we got to get a Baseline and
an intention before we go into a reading
sometimes but usually it's because the
person that died was amazing and there
was only one of them and this is
somebody that is sort of a a monarch
butterfly of the family that ever that
pulled everything together that was the
glue that one the person that went the
extra mile that made the holidays
special that made people feel loved that
was there when you were sitting at your
dad's funeral and held your hand without
you asking for anything from that person
they sensed you needed them that kind of
person comes through very easily and
amidst a lot of light do you come in
with a certain energy and that's what
you got or can that change in this
lifetime that's a really good question
and I will say this I have a very good
friend Tom McMullen who's a professional
astrologer and so sometimes we'll take
we I have my podcast the dead life and
around Halloween we'll do serial killers
charts and I profile the Dahmer one go I
did that one actually that's one of my
episodes and Ted Bundy we got we got
that one too and and it's horrible to
have to get into their energy and to
feel what their energy is but I asked
Tom I said can you see it in a birth
chart when somebody comes in is there
energy already set or can do is there
some free will involved here so we went
through all that and their charts
actually made a lot of sense in a very
grotesque way that they were born with
sort of tortured and demented energy but
he showed both the negative side of what
that chart could be which was the serial
killer or the positive of what that
could have been and it was just
interesting to see if you if you reach
for a higher vibration of who you are
which is what we've chosen to do in our
life this isn't easy you know but it's
it's not easy doing what we do but it
has a lot more rewards than the
difficulties of failing I rode low road
I mean in astrology there's a high road
and low road to every sign yes and we
all Bounce Around within the high road
low road but the whole goal is to get
high road right can you guess what I am
then you know I didn't even bother
looking up it's funny though
um you're pretty and your face is
symmetrical so usually that would be
Libra would be in the chart but the
other one and the other hand of Libra's
Aries which rules race car drivers
and you're exactly right I'm uh I'm a
double Aries sun and moon oh my God
that's memorizing I'm a Libra Rising too
and all of my Libra is in the first
house
wow so I have a ton of Aries energy and
I also have a lot of so I have like this
total eyewe like I we energy where I
like you know and Aries is such an
interesting sign because I don't know
what you think about it but it's even
being one it's not the one I can
pinpoint it's in my eyes too so I get it
yeah it's just a force like I've
realized that and Aries is a force it's
not like uh Leo Leo fire energy where
it's like haha look at me right it's a
different energy Sagittarius fire energy
where they're just like they say the
craziest oh my God they're
irreverent funny everybody loves them so
it's not like those kinds of fire
energies it's the one that you can't
pick out because it's just a force I'm a
Mars in Aries so I act and react with
the aggression but I'm a Libra Rising so
that the way I act and react opposes how
I'm seen so I'm aware that that's a
dynamic in my chart but I'm with you I
like being a mercenaries I drive too
fast I've taken race car driving school
actually at Bondurant
I would love that that would be great
Shannon would love that too our friend
Shannon oh my God I have stories about
her we'll have to talk well she's a
crazy stage that's why I always tell her
you're fired I'm like I love a sad they
say the craziest yes I love it yeah
that was that's most of our friends are
sad we had four birthday parties this
weekend it was like my brother his
girlfriend Catherine Anaya Shannon and
it was just nuts but it's they're fun
unless you get a dark sag I've seen dark
sages too when I'll post the astrology
for the moon every two and a half days
and they'll say I'm not the life of the
party I'm not fun and I'm like I
wouldn't admit that publicly I say
clearly you have something in your chart
that's an Affliction well I go there
okay let's face it they're right next to
Scorpio and those are not my favorite
actually sag borders are my least
favorite signs Capricorn and Scorpio
those are signs that I just can't get
down with Scorpios are like too
secretive for me yeah and Capricorns are
like two like
conniving
the motto for Capricorns I use
so they're all about the money the
foundation building and what they
deserve so that's the downside of
Capricorn there can be a positive I have
one Capricorn friend and if they're
opposition's cancer because it's six
months across from them so a lot of
people will draw the energy of their
opposing sign so my friend Tammy
actually draws cancer energies makes her
nurturing and motherly but she also owns
a magazine you know which is Capricorn
yeah so yeah it's just I do have you
know
um uh Alisa Romeo wrote a book called
meet your soul I don't know if you've
heard of it I think at least as a
Capricorn and she totally gives the
motherly like let me give back like I I
write a book I have this business but
like I'm trying to help people so I can
get down with that cap energy but like
most of the time it's those two are my
uh definitely not my favorite signs
there are Cancers that draw Capricorn
energy to too so you have to watch that
now not all cancers act like Moon
children sometimes they can be very
serious and go into government work or
accounting which would be Capricorn
rules the government and anything that
sort of patriarchal in a foundation so
it's just interesting and then cancer is
the opposite they want to be children
forever and they want to be babied and I
love that because I have one I mean
we're talking about like communicating
with the dead but now we're talking
about astrology what is the link there
and what why how did you get into
astrology I was surprised when I learned
that I was like oh interesting like I
just because they're kind of they're not
they're not totally different they're
out in this sort of esoteric realm real
yeah but I'm just curious we're under
the same umbrella actually how it
happened for me and I am Aquarius and
Aquarius does rule astrology we just
naturally can read a chart without
knowing specifics of the rules of a
straw apology so I was able to do that
in my late 20s and I had gone to
audition because I was being studied by
scientists at a university to figure out
how I was doing what I was doing and
they were contacted by Paramount and
Paramount said send us some of your best
mediums so I was one of the ones that
was sent and I competed against 120
other people in rooms in Tarot astrology
profiling mediums like I went up against
them to form the five oracles because
the show is going to be called the
oracles and it's new no this was a long
time ago in my 20s thing okay okay so I
went there and Kelsey Grammar was
producing that that's how I met Kelsey
he was the executive producer of medium
that's how that came to be that's how we
met but I became friends with some of
the astrologers when I was there and we
just I started picking it up and
learning the energy so now I can be
around somebody and feel an energy and
know that that's in their chart I had a
guy from Dish Nation once I thought this
was funny like he was so
um you'll get the tone of him anyways he
looks at me and he says what am I and I
said well said kind of got a pointy nose
so you probably are Aries and he looked
at me and and then I said is that your
real nose or did you get that done and
he was like you and I was like
that's right
you're like you want to be a smart ass
yep I took it to another level and I
enjoyed it
that's always the problem when you're
witty and got that fire in you which you
do is that it's not usually the first
offender that gets to be looked at as
like the fire like the tough one yeah
but you start a fight and I promise I'll
Burn It To The Ground that's Aries I
know I got I have that too yes I know
it's our temper for sure yeah it's also
your road it's also your charm and the
fact that we're Libra risings our our
rising sign tries to keep our sort of
Beast under control which is Aries so
Libra is working overtime for you and
for me trying to keep us
um aware of what we're about to say
without just blurting it out because we
can burn down a house with words because
we have that Libra in our chart so it's
just as how you see it we'll seek that
it's like how we see Justice how should
we like how should we use astrology I'm
I'm like Curious for myself even I took
a couple levels of astrology so I have a
fairly decent database of knowledge when
it comes to it yes um and like it can
become very consuming and it's also
kind of hard to apply a lot of times
it's futuristic and it's easier to see
in hindsight so what is the frequency
and the right information to take from
astrology to be sort of useful some
astrology isn't particularly useful it's
entertaining let's just say like gen Z
loves astrology right now they're
entertained by it you know they have
co-star apps and they're like looking at
what's going on my friend Tom practices
a particular kind of astrology that is
karmic and it looks at you on a soul
level what is your karma what do you
have to do to achieve your Dharma is
there a Karma that is multi-generational
for instance in my family the women
always depended on the men
for for the financial support and they
were the little Housewives and I
remember growing up being incensed
because I'm a mercenaries uh incensed
that they would actually get an
allowance that bothered me badly and I
said I'm gonna grow up and make my own
money so then I had three daughters who
I also raised to grow up and be
self-sufficient so I broke my karma and
achieved my Dharma so he does that sort
of a reading in with what he sees in
your chart and I find those useful
because some people need it spelled out
for them what's what they should have
seen all along and if you step back long
enough and you're objective and you look
at it objectively you can see that
there's a pattern in the family or in
your life that needs to be broken and he
also sees your past life in your chart
and and why you brought that in and
that's very helpful too to know that
there was a reason for instance there's
some people that he's had as clients I
remember this one story they they
couldn't step foot into a church this
was something that bothered them and
when he went into the chart now he
didn't know that piece of information
but he went into the chart and he said
um you were burned alive by the church
and in the name of God you were you were
murdered and that's why they couldn't
step into the church and so it was
interesting for him to identify that and
then for the person to realize that and
to be able to put that to bed and not
have to carry that with them anymore
because there was an energy brought in
from a past life what kind of astrologer
or reader should people be looking for
because like Tom can't read for everyone
so what kind of person should people
look for for that information
evolutionary astrology is the type that
Tom practices I always find word of
mouth with anything is the best way to
go which is why your podcast is great
because you know even with mediumship
I've had people say well we went to this
one medium and she said that my dad they
said she couldn't reach her the father
of the client that he wasn't on the
other side that he didn't go to a good
place or something and I said they're
full of I said that's you can still
get them you can still get their energy
there's no reason she couldn't get it's
never the dead that's hard to get you
can anybody can be brought through it's
the living and getting the living's
energy adjusted for a reading so the
fact that she said that he couldn't be
reached on the other side I'm like what
was there a bad connection what is that
or maybe that person shouldn't be
practicing professionally and I do see a
lot of people in the Ethereal business
um that really aren't good enough to to
do it professionally because you're
really taking somebody's life into your
hands in advising them oh for sure so
what are some bad signs like for someone
so if they can't bring someone through
or there are a couple others that are
red flags because people take this
information apart and that's good and I
wrote a chapter in my first book my
first book was don't kiss them goodbye
and I wrote a chapter on what to look
for for cons or people who you know uh
practice I find certain like voodoo-ish
Santeria more toned practices to be a
little darker in energy so I tend to
stay away from that personally because I
fix a lot of people that are sort of
ruined by a reading under that umbrella
um if they say money's ruining your life
you're not finding love because
um you know you're too focused on money
bring me three thousand dollars tightly
wrapped or in a box and I'm gonna I'm
gonna say a blessing and and rid your
life of that and then you're gonna find
love Yeah walk away you might even call
the police that's just straight up and
that happens for cash God damn it I've
been there
you know so if if they're asking you to
bring them a lot of uh stacks of money
that they're gonna throw over a bridge
and say a spell for and and rid you of
that evil in your life
you need to be talking to somebody more
than a psychic if you're at that point
in your life it's like you got take the
three thousand dollars get your hair
done get your eyebrows tweezed uh go buy
a new outfit and have one too many
martinis with your girlfriends and act
like you don't care it's like a magnet
for guys not hard
I bet you and Shannon can go to town on
that situation oh my gosh he's also the
queen of that girls I need to we need to
go for drinks you need to teach me your
ways okay okay you mentioned past lives
and I'm really fascinated with this so
I'm obviously then you believe in
reincarnation I do okay so how does that
work how does reincarnation work okay so
um reincarnation is for Souls who feel
and I had Steven Simon on my podcast and
he was a producer of Somewhere in Time
do you remember that with Jane Seymour
and Christopher Reeve where he goes back
in time to find his love oh my God you
have to watch it okay anyways I had him
on and it was interesting because you
can make a pact with somebody you love
before you cross and sort of design what
your other side is going to look like
together when you die so if one goes
first the other knows what to expect but
if you should get there to the other
side and and feel oh I didn't have
children in this lifetime I'd like to
have that Soul experience or I didn't
find love in this lifetime I'd like to
find that Soul experience you can
recycle you can you can come back for
another Soul lesson
sometimes and most of the time people
come back because they didn't figure out
in this lifetime what they were supposed
to and so they end up having to come
back sometimes they just really enjoy
the chaos of the Living World so they
keep coming back out of Adventure and
that's Karma a little bit too right I
feel like when I listen have listened to
Dolores Cannon stuff it's like very much
about that like you didn't learn your
lesson you're going to come back and
have to do it again you know in my
switch positions you might be the boy
instead of the girl whatever right
well that's why with soul mates some
people will have a child and say when
they were born I felt complete and
they're my little soul mate they
probably were
um family in other lifetimes and they
keep coming back together and same with
romantic soul mates you can decide you
want to come back and find each other
again and live that life so it's really
what the soul is craving as in on a
growth level the coming back and it's
the same with um miscarriages
stillborns like with babies that don't
make it but a couple weeks after after
being born they don't form their
personalities yet the body was unable to
sustain them so they recycle back into
the family they find a way back into the
family whether it be as your son or
daughter or your niece or nephew but
they find a way back into the family so
souls are here for a reason and I'm
looking what's up animals I don't know
about reincarnation for Animals because
when I bring people through I see the
animals over there and I have dads come
through and they're like I have your
damn cat you know don't worry about it
they've got to come back as an animal it
was it's not like you have a life and
then you decide hey I'm going to come
back as an animal because there are
people that I've witnessed that just
feel like insanely can I mean I love
animals but you know people that like
are devastated afterwards like it was
their oh no I meet those people too I
total I get what you're saying um
they're the animals are
pure Souls they're just pure Souls so
the people that get attached to them as
if they're their own children like their
own biological children or their husband
even
um needs something they're on a deep
level usually they're broken or there
was a victimization when they were
younger or they take they had trust
issues with people usually this isn't
all this is usually and when that's the
case it's the animal that they're able
to
feel safe with yeah and feel that deep
connection with knowing that dog cat
parrot whatever isn't going to hurt them
and so it's sort of a
um an endless true love for them because
it's safe it's safe and it's meaningful
and so I get I get why animals are very
healing but there's no growth in that
though right because if there's no
challenge there's not any growth that's
right they're they're deciding not to
meet the challenge that they're not
going to grow on the soul level they
came into
break the victimization energy to
prevent others from being victimized to
you know you're supposed to do something
with it for instance I had an attempted
abduction on me when I was 11. this is
here in Phoenix and while I was riding
my bike and it triggered something in me
um because I Heard a Voice on the other
in my head saying go and it was flashing
my house in my head like go and so these
guys that pulled up next to me on my
bike when I was 11 which is the age most
children under 18 most that are murdered
are girls
around the age of 11. and
they were like drunk and I know that now
because I didn't understand why they
smelled like Susie's dad my friend's dad
smells like beer a lot you know and so I
didn't know what was going on but they
said come over here come over here you
know we want to give you a ride and I
said I live right there like my house is
right there and they're like no just
come here and I froze and the images of
my house kept being flashed through my
head and I took off on my bike and I
went home and I told my mom and she did
what the majority of parents do with
attempted abduction and and she did not
report it when that happened I decided I
wanted to do something when I grew up to
help kids because I didn't understand
why grown-ups wanted to hurt children it
just didn't make sense to me it didn't
seem natural and I just didn't
understand that motive but I initiated
the amber alert for the State of Arizona
in 2000 and I served on the task force
to design it so in that moment when I
did that whatever victim energy I may
have brought in from another lifetime I
stood up and and countered it
and I was very proud of that and the
first three kids that were saved from
the Amber Alert here in Arizona I was
like those were mine because if I hadn't
initiated the alert those feet you know
yes it would have happened eventually
but those first few would have fallen
between the cracks so I was very very
proud of that
yeah that is amazing yeah so what are
those people then the ones that can do
something like that that can abduct a
child abuse a child sexually physically
what's going on well there's different
forms of deviant energy going on in them
i i profiled Killers
um for uh the prosecution years ago and
I had to get into the head of the people
or if somebody's murdered I can Bridge
myself through the living person into
the perpetrator and so I did that for 20
years I just retired and um holy heavy
so I've actually had to get in the heads
of those people and feel that attraction
to the child and I have to do it to
establish motive in order to help law
enforcement so motive is important it
can be Financial financially motivated
it could be sexually motivated there's
more of a demented energy when I tap
into someone that's uh attracted to
children and
um so those people I think is it's
biological I don't think it's just their
chart I think you could find a marker in
their chart but I believe that's
biological they had wanted to study
Dahmer's brain and the parents said no
and I wish they had allowed that because
I'm positive they're going to find a
biological reason of how somebody the
perversion was something that was of our
body and not of the energy of the person
that came in because some of them
actually feel guilty and remorse and
then there's the ones that don't and
those are the ones that I wanted Tom to
run their charts because I wanted to see
if that was born like that or if it
became like that and the common
denominator on the serial killers I
would say the lack of empathy that there
whether they're a psychopath or a
sociopath it's the lack of empathy they
absolutely feel nothing and to them it's
just an adrenaline rush when they go in
for the kill it's and they do it just
for that that Rush of getting away with
it some of it's sometimes it's arrogance
like Ted Bundy he was arrogant and he he
really liked being able to
lure and trick uh his victims into going
with him he's the one that wore the cast
on his arm so they thought he needed
help which a little Silence of the Lamb
uh movie clip they sort of showed that
in it where he needed help putting the
sofa in the back of the van and pushed
the girl into the van when she was
trying to help him but she thought he
was safe because you know he was on
crutches or in a wheelchair so they lure
you and it's that getting away with it
and that you fell for it it's just like
shooting a deer to them or trapping a
rabbit like almost a sliding scale from
a narcissist in a way yeah Ted Bundy had
a little of that narcissism going on on
his chart he had a lot of things
he his grandfather was speculated to
have actually been his father so there
was a lot going on there so I think you
know biology knock knock hey scientists
study that look at that yeah but is that
part of there is that is everything is
it is it
I don't know that doesn't sound like
free will but free will versus
determinism so is there a plan coming in
is that part of the plan the lesson to
learn it could be the challenge no it
could be that Souls the souls challenge
that we're going to give you something
that you're going to really want and we
need you to in order to grow to
um
Reserve yourself and not act on impulse
you know that you're going to have to
Vibe with your higher sense of self in
this lifetime and if you don't you're
going to be the worst of the worst but
if you do you're going to be great and
you'll overcome it so it's not that you
can overcome being attracted to children
but you could help for instance if you
were going to Vibe with a higher
frequency you could become an FBI
profiler and be somebody who goes after
them
so that would be the other side of the
coin there that they could choose but
didn't didn't fell right into the
impulse and the the
um desire to kill and once they kill one
they're not gonna stop I don't know why
they ever let people out of jail that
have killed especially in that manner
it's just beyond me
same with those that touch kids it's
just not something they can get better
from it just doesn't make any sense it's
like rolling the dice it's weird yeah
uh something that's becoming more
popular that I'm curious how spirit and
energies play into is
um plant medicine
and what is going on in that realm and
is that dangerous and how important is
it to set the room at the intention the
energy the protection I can hook you up
with um my professor of Earth Magic
Margaret Jamison she is a
multi-generational Appalachian granny
um so meaning witch
a little bit a little bit of a winch and
so was her great grandmother and it went
on down the line and she was taught the
Spells and the potions and she grows all
the herbs that's where I get my
um protection oils and herbal
supplements as well you know I have a
naturopath that I go to and I would just
be off the rails without her and there's
nothing pharmaceutical grade in it it's
I take ADR which feeds your adrenal
glands so that that's where you process
your stress through so you don't short
circuit so I'm able to handle stress
better and she ran my blood panels and
she said your testosterone and this your
estrogen are off the chart so I actually
have to take pills to dump testosterone
and estrogen because I just have too
much I'm like why am I so weird
so wow well I mean like I think that for
I mean in researching because I also
love health and wellness so if you can
increase your testosterone by like if
you have like if you're a guy I heard
this you know if you have like dumbbells
and power tools laying around these
things keep your testosterone up just as
just the same you know you're talking
about the cancer energy men's
testosterone actually drops when they
become a dad and they're more sedentary
and they're kind of caretaking like the
it's kind of interesting if it's sort of
the chicken or the egg thing because you
know certain things can rise make it go
up but then other things make it go down
so I think that testosterone makes it
harder for them when they get angry
it they become more reactionary yeah and
and I I know what that feels like
because I have too much to surround and
estrogen well thank God I don't because
I don't have that high of testosterone
and I'm an Aries so I'd be totally
screwed if I did I know it's you know
yeah it's why I don't carry weapons in
the car
yeah it's it's interesting
to know what's going on with your body
and take and be able to take care of
yourself but also on a hormonal level
men have this issue too but they're not
really being treated for what their
bodies are going through as they go
through the decades as well and women
are just sort of oh you're just going
through you know menopause or
perimenopause and they don't really look
at their depression or the fluctuation
going on within them in their hormones
and treat it naturally instead of trying
to medicate the hell out of everybody
you know the only medication I once like
in a Martini you know that's good I'll
take that the martini it was like an
olive couple olives right it's just well
my grandfather is actually German and he
always kept a bottle of Jager in the
freezer instead of had medicinal
purposes so whatever for we get a sore
throat you do a shot at Jaeger hey man
this stuff's biological I wore a
continuous blood glucose monitor and
when I'd have a glass of wine yeah my
blood sugar would drop because I would
go more into parasympathetic and relax
wow that's interesting
looks like some monitors up to all of us
and test them on martinis and then the
next day we'll try tequila Shannon's
favorite and then the next day we'll try
wine my favorite that's so funny I'm
more of a girl yeah vodka tequila and
wine we could just rotate them all the
time we could
um so so is plant medicine a bad idea or
a good idea you know especially after
what we all just went through in the
pandemic I'm not telling people how to
think I'm just saying this is how I feel
I don't fully trust anything I'm hearing
coming out of like Western medicine
right now so I feel much safer going the
on natural routes and take my D3 and
vitamin C and and you know let my immune
system work for me right now and not
um and not listen to everything that's
being said so my body's great I was a
kid that ate dirt we have high immune
systems I mean we're those kids they put
us all together when one of them had the
chickenpox so everybody could get it
over with at the same time you know our
immune systems are strong I'm worried
about the younger people that just went
through the two years lockdown because
their immune systems are shot they
didn't get that that herd immunity uh
being in the classroom and so I do worry
for them but as far as my age group oh
my God no what I was my we had a popcorn
ceiling and I thought popcorn this was
the stupidest things adults could have
done popcorn that sounds amazing so I'm
standing on the back of the couch
picking it off and tasting it to see see
if it tastes like popcorn now they have
lawsuits for asbestos language
abracadabra
[Laughter]
so wait so plant medicine is a bad idea
no I'm a good idea better better than
taking statins better than taking you
know synthetics
information yeah I mean it's just it
feels right to me I you know everybody's
got to do what's right for them but for
me that works but you should have
Margaret on your show sometimes she is a
plethora of information when it comes to
the plants and the herbs and the
properties in in the potions and such so
um yeah it makes me think about
timelines do you get a feeling about
that is it when someone's gonna die no
not necessarily but like shifting
timelines in your life like like moving
a trajectory of like every decision this
is what I've sort of come to at least
think at this point in time based on my
research and watching lots of videos and
listening to things is that every
decision branches off to a new timeline
like through our life so that's so we
have these infinite amount of potential
timelines going on and we the idea and
what I at least always hope and pray for
is that like whatever is meant to come
through to be in service to my highest
good and highest timeline right and so
like with plant medicine right I feel
like I skip a whole shitload of
timelines I'm like my internal and
external reality match when I go in but
when I come out they don't match anymore
and it takes time for the external
reality to catch up to the internal
reality and it feels to me like a like a
major leap of timelines because once
you've experienced those things and seen
what you've seen and felt what you've
felt and know what you know now you just
can't go back so is timeline something
that play into information that comes
from the other side
um as far as I think occurrences in our
life happening to in our highest and
best good you know trying to get us
where we need to be I believe there are
some moments that are fated in our lives
um that are that are going to happen
um
I I also look at my own life which has
an extraordinary butterfly effect of
things that have happened and affected
other parts of my life in a Continuum
like it just
keeps opening up from things from when I
was a child or you're a teenager or in
my 20s and
um all made me who I am for sure I think
the people that don't really grow are
mostly the ones that don't go anywhere
you are someone that when somebody says
here's an invitation come to my party
you're like yeah I'm there that sounds
great
um so you're giving yourself that
opportunity to meet someone to fall in
love you're making it a possibility for
you so I find action in your life
important and getting you where you need
to go but your double areas so you've
got plenty of action going on in your
energy as far as taking anything and
seeing different things and timelines
I'd have to go more in depth with you
and talk to you about that because I
don't know if you mean like mushrooms or
if you mean like I mean more like like
my reality has to change in reflection
to now what I know feels like whatever
trajectory I was on it's shifted okay
that doesn't mean you were taken off
your path totally like there's an
infinite amount of potential paths right
so it's just saying to me it feels like
more information
and more knowing and that is kind of
Leaping you into the next into another
reality that's not just like one
decision away it's like it's a very big
jump right okay so that's why with what
I do with energy work when when in doubt
or when you don't know which path to
take or if you did the right thing it's
the inner voice you refer to your inner
voice will always guide you always get
you where you need to be you never have
to feel lost as long as you connect with
that Center of power inside of you
that's your vehicle guiding you on your
journey and you'll get where you're
supposed to go like what is is getting
us through this life because I also had
a crazy experience in EMDR where have
you ever take done EMDR it's not a drug
it's a it's a therapy it's like a buzzer
and it's it's basically uh it's a rapid
eye movement desensitive desensitization
so by doing this rapid eye movement
whether someone does this to you or I
have a buzzer in each hand
um it bypasses your natural pattern of
thinking and allows you to access
memories from this point in time now so
you literally like time travel and go
back and reprogram the memory because
you have no emotion now so in these like
Journeys through EMDR which are I mean
it's EMDR sounds like some major like
thing it's not it's it's not it's not a
crazy deal
um but you just sit there and you know
the play the buzzer and 30 seconds later
you know you open your eyes and your
therapist is like what did you see and
so you I tell her what I noticed and so
one of the things that I noticed a
couple times in the most recent round
that I did is that um is that there is
an orchestration happening to me meaning
like there's a certain energy or there's
a certain energy or Collective or Spirit
um or plan that's literally like turning
my head at the right moment and going
you need to see this right or you know
putting me in a situation to have an
experience or making a difficult
situation so that I get the lesson to be
able to achieve something else that is
required of me to go through challenge
it sounds like you're firing on all
cylinders and it's it's most no this is
a good thing most people that I come
across I'm there are some people I the
dead always tell me that they're more
alive than we are and I believe them and
I see people out there that classify
themselves as living people that have no
life or they emit no energy they don't
project anything they're just sort of
going through the motions of eating and
working and coming home and there's no
real joy and I feel really badly for
them and so they're they're firing on no
cylinders you're firing on all cylinders
so you came into this lifetime and
you're just saying I'm gonna do it all
you can't tell me I'm just this I can be
this too and I'm going to do everything
so you're gonna end up Crossing that
Finish Line when you die with your hair
on fire and this is how I want to go
high-fiving the Dead who are like that
was legendary and I'm like
yes I did it all and and and then
they're going to have an amazing drink
waiting for us because we did it and
took it on the chin and broke glass
ceilings and you know I always said you
don't break a glass ceiling without
getting cut because I broke so many when
medium came out and totally you broke
them in race car driving in being not
just a woman but a beautiful woman that
had to deal with men
and that that's wasn't all bad you know
they were complementary at times too
well you know and then the wives had to
have looked at you like oh God you're
happy you learn you learn Girl Code real
quick yeah okay okay well see but you're
somebody who would wouldn't be an issue
that's for if a woman was insecure you'd
be an issue but not if they're secure
um but you broke glass ceilings as well
and I actually I know this sounds
strange I enjoyed the cuts getting cut
breaking that glass ceiling I'd rather
feel that and be totally alive then go
through the motions of life like some
people that I see out there who I my
clients I'm like wake up take risks what
are you doing they're like when am I
gonna meet my husband I'm like when are
you gonna get out of the house you know
so normal is something I hope no one
describes me as you know what I'm I'm on
board with that that we were born to
stand out not to fit in and I don't
understand why some people still want to
fit in it's okay to be a rebel it's okay
to live out loud and you don't have to
apologize for it
it's what I'm so glad you did I'm so
glad that so many do say yes but the
ones that don't I think that it's their
confidence that tells them that they
won't be okay but it's in fact what
makes them very special is what I try
and tell people is like what is
different about you is actually what's
going to make you valuable and special
yes that's true that's true and all the
people in grade school and Junior High
and high school that didn't have time
for you are going to tell everybody how
they met you and how they knew you so
it's all good totally okay so how do we
work with our work with our higher self
our oversoul and all of our guides like
what is our what is our what is our real
reality as you know it this is I mean
how I live anyways um for me my dad died
20 years ago and I started talking to
him when I do a reading I'm like can you
hone their energy can you focus them
turn up their volume and so he does that
for me on the other side we work in
concert but you also have relatives on
the other side who feel connected to you
that you might be named after or you
could have a a great great aunt Sophie
who was a rebel like you who Vibes with
you and and walks with you so they
connect to us in ways that are on a soul
level and they they try and guide us
there are also these other guides who
may have been in your profession
who feel like in one lifetime they
didn't get everything out they wanted to
do and they'll help you if they Vibe
with you they'll help you so I could
have other mediums who lived who give me
their energy you could have race car
drivers from the past that Focus their
energy on you in moments of Panic or
down to the wire moments they talk to us
they guide us
they share their knowledge with us and
so there are many different entities on
the other side that if you're an active
Soul as we are they're there with you
and that can just be somebody trying to
Wrangle their five kids I mean that's an
act of Soul too I just mean somebody who
is making connections emotionally out
there in the world and trying to leave
the world in a better place and for the
people who do nothing the world's worse
off for it you know if they had if I had
done nothing the Amber Alert wouldn't
have come out for another year or so you
know and then that whole year all the
kids that would have fallen between the
cracks if I hadn't been willing to take
it on the chin and go up against all the
Skeptics and I went up against all the
Skeptics very publicly and um then
things wouldn't have changed Minds
wouldn't have opened medium wouldn't
have come out if I hadn't been willing
to be studied by scientists
um and published an academic journal
what if I sucked what if I was afraid of
that what if what if I scored low what
happens then I didn't let my head go
there I just did it I put it on the line
This is my talent this is what I can do
if it's not good enough I don't belong
here in this field and I was ready to go
back to law school
so either way you know and um everybody
in publishing said your books will never
sell don't kiss them goodbye that
title's got to be changed we are their
Heaven you've got to change that title
that'll never sell nope nope they
finally stopped asking me to change my
titles because I wasn't gonna do it and
they sold just fine
so I was I'm a New York Times
best-selling author so people the titles
actually resonated with people and
people thanked me for that so people
that are out there in the physical world
giving you advice don't always know what
they're talking about so you've got to
weigh it with your inner energy force
and see what makes sense for you but I'm
just saying with what I just did in my
life if I was one of those people that
was afraid and lived in fear and I would
say life doesn't mean live in fear every
day that's not what life stands for and
if I had lived afraid in the in the
shadows all that wouldn't have happened
so how many good things haven't happened
out there in the world because there are
people that kept their mouth shut and
didn't follow their path so I think
that's why we do what we do to try and
Inspire other people to go yeah yeah I
can do that I can do that and they can I
did this past life regression and
um in this regression I ended up
making it to the coast which is where I
was trying to go I was kind of like a
Native American Medicine Woman and I got
there and I realized that I had this
pouch full of medicine and it was like
way way back in the old like ancient
more not ancient but like old old times
like when California it was California
it was just being kind of different it
would have been it would have been La
when La was brand new and it was like uh
there was all there was a market I was
like oh well I'll I'll bring my I'll do
a table and have my medicine and nobody
wanted it so I was like hmm okay so then
I started doing these little ceremonies
that night with with anyone that would
come but it turned out only really only
be women and so I did this for like 10
years and we sort of cultivated our
magic and all kinds of things and the
men grew to not like it and so I either
had to leave or I had to stop doing my
magic and I stopped doing my magic Wow
and so if I didn't stop doing my magic
and I didn't leave the energy was that I
would die I would be killed for it right
so but the point of the story damn
persecuting women what is that
the point of the story that's coming to
an end
um the uh the point of the story is that
I died anyway not doing my magic
I removed in the in the regression I
like was up like on the second floor
like whatever living space and I was
like probably 40 when I I had to stop
and I was like 70 and I just died and I
it was like it was like 30 years went
blank in the regression like I don't
know what happened because I died like
energetically I died not doing my magic
and living in my truth and so you can
either die doing your magic or die
anyway not doing it and the the better
off to choose life and light and energy
and um because the result is could be
the same in the end and so you might as
well live in Integrity yeah so that's
kind of what I heard you say is just
that you know you just gotta live in
your truth and you got to be honest and
you have to be brave and I think people
are afraid to be honest with themselves
I think that almost is harder for them
than The Bravery interestingly enough
being honest with themselves and seeing
themselves for who they really are are
and who they could be and doing the work
to become that person it's worth it but
a lot of people will just keep doing the
wrong thing again and again because it's
what they know it's familiar it's why a
lot of women pick a pattern of man out
there in the world and they keep drawing
in the same kind over and over again who
disappoints them again and again and
they still keep doing it because it's
familiar to them even though it hurts
it's like I don't know it's a hundred
percent chance that it's gonna hurt if
you do that or you could do something
completely the opposite of who that guy
is and there's a really good chance that
he's not going to be as bad as all of
the others that are your type I think
why do you think it's hard for for
people to be honest with themselves I
don't think people are quiet enough in
their head often enough to even get to
know themselves I think a lot of people
don't really know who they are they
don't pay enough attention to themselves
because they're too busy giving their
energy way to everybody else even on
social media look at how much energy is
expelled on social media that those
people aren't putting into friends or
family and you know with what we have to
do even as public figures you know it's
part of what we signed up for but
there's some people out there that
didn't sign up for it that just
willingly give their energy away and I
don't always understand why when they
could put it back in themselves and have
realizations in themselves but they need
strangers validation more than they need
to
advance on a soul level or to look
inward I just don't think kids are
taught to look Inward and In some
cultures they are and it's why they
evolve and they're so Zen and then we've
got when I went to Japan on tour I loved
it everybody was sort of centered and
take kind and they were kind like truly
kind and patient and I came back here
and my energy adjusted to the American
Energy and I was like oh my God we are
so uptight it was like just so amazing
well it's all the it's all the
protection through uh protection of the
of the pattern that the ego has now
created a job to defend and it's just a
whole bunch of like excuses victim
blaming whiny we're we're we judge it's
like oh my God stop just stop I don't
think some people know how to even stop
themselves from continuing a pattern
that they just keep perpetuating and
that is repelling they don't know they
have a pattern I they don't even know
yeah they don't know they don't even
look they don't even think about it it's
just I think we need to teach young
people to do a little bit more inner
soul searching and connecting with the
source of our energy rather than
go get a boob job as soon as you turn 18
or go get your lips done you know and
you'll be more valuable you know that's
the important most important energy to
connect with is yourself is it important
to connect with other energies ascended
masters or Angels or anything like that
I've heard that they need you to ask
them for help for them to help so is
that an important could that be a really
helpful thing in life I've I've always
said that it's your intention you have
to State your intention to them what you
want what you need from them and as soon
as you do they'll deliver it for you
they want to be invited back into your
life so when I read my clients at the
end I say okay they want to be part of
your life still and they often talk
about you're not a you're not a
an orphan you know the the parents are
like you're not an orphan you still have
a mom you still have a dad and the kids
that come through say I'm still part of
the family I'm still part of the family
and they like stated and own it and they
need us to say we still want you in our
lives you know there's a place for you
at the table during the holidays
um your ornaments high up on the tree
and it makes us smile and we love
including you in our lives and we're not
holding them here hostage it's not like
that they stay because without us their
Heavens not complete so they're waiting
for us
because we are their Heaven that's why I
titled my second book we are their
Heaven because I noticed they kept
coming back to the living even though
they could be on the other side with all
the people that they miss they keep
coming back to their children or to
their parents because their their heaven
isn't complete without us so they go
back and forth between the worlds and
how special are we because we see
ourselves as so insignificant sometimes
how special are we that we're versions
of somebody's heaven like they show me
memories that they are reliving that
include the person that's still alive
being five years old and you know Mommy
carrying him from the wedding he was
just dancing in a little suit and
um and and he fell asleep on her
shoulder and that's her Heaven that's a
version of her heaven so throughout our
lives we're adding all of these
Beautiful Moments to lives that when our
physical bodies die is what we relive on
the other side so you're creating your
versions of Heaven here so you want to
make it good
don't suck come on and and I wish people
in the physical world would see on a
soul level how important they are to
those that that come through and say
um you you made me feel needed again you
know I love you and I have grandmothers
that are that felt more like that was
their child you know the grandchild
because they helped raise them and so
there's so there's like a soul mate
connection between grandmothers
sometimes in the grains it's just very
beautiful the strings are very glittery
and they're beautiful and they're thin
but strong and they connect us all
living and dead and I just I hope the
living wake up a little bit and put
themselves out there little bit more and
and and shine yeah for who they are does
that do those lives when they cross over
do they are they able to reincarnate and
still have that sort of timeline or that
reality like continue as a Continuum or
do they have to complete something
before they can reincarnate some don't
want to come back some already had their
perfect life and they stay with that
person and the people connected to them
on the other side there's nothing more
for them to achieve they've done
everything and they've come back time
and time again and they've got the Holy
Grail finally and they stay they stay
over there and they're like I'm blessed
and they live in that nature and then
they help other people in the physical
world
the people that didn't evolve they do
come back and there's something that
they actually agree on the other side
that they need to learn and that it
might be hard and they know what they're
going to go through but they say I can
do it I can handle it but then sometimes
they're given a body with a chemical
imbalance or some sort of challenge they
didn't foresee and it's up to them to
overcome it
it's hard to be human I'm sure you've
answered this many times and I don't
like to ask questions that you've
probably been asked before as much as
humanly possible but I do want to know
like what the most sort of common
message from the other side is to help
us to live a better life like what is it
that they want to tell us the the don't
live in fear one is a very big one that
they come through with and say take
risks be who you are
don't worry about me I know how much you
love me that's another big one there are
no goodbyes for the people that are hung
up over they didn't get to their dad's
bedside before he died or or their moms
or they weren't there with their child
when they died
there are no goodbyes so they're like
don't get hung up on that word
I'm still here we're still going to be
together and then when my dad died and
this helped me
I heard a voice and it's told me every
day you wake up is a good day
every day you wake up is a day closer to
seeing your dad again he's not your past
he's your present and future you're not
leaving him behind you're moving towards
him and then when I would get out of bed
the next day I recognized I was a day
closer to him and it it it healed
something in me to know that and if it's
perspective we're actually moving
towards them why are we spending so much
time being sad they want us to take the
risk they didn't take in life they want
us to go on the trips that we say we'll
go in five years you know uh I don't
have the money now do what a 19 year old
would do wing it you know yeah get a
backpack find a cheap way don't stay at
the Ritz whatever but get there because
five years may not come for you and I
see that happen all the time so I do
stupid things like I wanted to eat Lucky
Charms in Ireland because I promised 11
year old Allison me that I would one day
when I was eating my Lucky Charms I'm
like I'm gonna go to Ireland I'm going
to eat Lucky Charms there and I did and
I rolled down a hill of clovers so my
list is maybe different than other
people but it brings me joy oh my God
it's all about I can't believe I didn't
have that one my last name is Patrick
you'd think I'd want to go eat Lucky
Charms in Ireland and Landon and find
the pot of gold at the end of the Clover
Hill that's what I'm talking about put
it on your list totally I made the silly
mistake of deciding that the only thing
on my bucket list was running a marathon
and that was just I don't know that's
not a common thing you can constantly
add to your list good good good I'm good
I drew a livingless not the dead list
this is the living this is the living
list things you want to take with you to
the other side these memories these
moments and I drink champagne over
licking the Eiffel Tower with my husband
on Valentine's Day it was awesome so
I rented out an entire movie theater to
watch Xanadu
so I believe you believe it can happen
believe if you deserve it write it down
and make it happen and and share it with
other people that you love like enjoy it
together it's great it's great it's
exciting true well thank you so much
you're so much I could keep going on and
on but
um this is good for now so I'll see you
for drinks on a Friday night right
sounds good you've got mine you've got
my phone number
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button